bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
nouvelle année oblige et nouvelle
présidente pour saint quentin en
yvelines de nouvelles perspectives se
dessinent pour l'agglomération économie
mobilité commerces entreprises comme ici
nous qui cube
qu'est ce qui attend les
saint-quentinoises et les saint
quentinois pour 2018 ou fait le point
c'est parti
[Musique]
et
nous sommes avant tout chose aller voir
les saint-quentinoises et les saint
quentinois afin de savoir ce qu'il
souhaite pour cette nouvelle année
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faits déjà le vélodrome c'est une ville
dynamique peut-être l'accessibilité de
saint quentin
voilà depuis paris ont peut-être un tram
en plus d'accessibilité facilité d'accès
on est tout à fait des places de parking
gratuites par exemple beaucoup trop
construit beaucoup trouvaient tony chan
que ça manque énormément d'espacés verts
tire l accès aux
aux structures sportives par exemple
comme aux états unis
24 h/24 ou alors sur une plage horaire
plus large que ce qu'on trouve
maintenant saint quentin en yvelines à
40 ans aux portes de la capitale
l'agglomération a secret l'attractivité
ses entreprises ses universités et
grandes écoles
ces laboratoires de recherche des
équipements culturels et sportifs
d'envergure l'agglomération se veut
terre d'innovation et ne souhaite pas
s'arrêter en si bon chemin
le projet de territoire ce qui demain
sera lancé dans le courant de l'année
son but connectez habitants usagers
salariés chefs d'entreprises
responsables associatifs et acteurs du
monde culturel et sportif
le projet créer de nouvelles synergies
qui profiteront à tous donc aujourd'hui
que nous sommes là nous on va pouvoir
faire un travail de fond et pour cela
prendre les trois quatre mois qui sont
devant nous pour pouvoir peaufiner et
bien ce ski demain qui est ce projet
territoire que nous souhaitons tous pour
pouvoir imaginer notre territoire sur
les 20 30 ans à venir dans cette terre
d'innovation et bien tous les secteurs
vont être trop grosse et si je peux me
permettre l'expression du développement
durable au développement économique au
social à l'accompagnement
intergénérationnel à la culture au sport
on a pu ressortir du diagnostic que nous
avions un potentiel très fort au niveau
de notre développement économique est
également commerciales et aussi de
l'habitat les on s'est rendu compte
aussi qui avait un manque clairement de
longvic peut-être de rester sur notre
territoire à la tête du territoire
depuis octobre 2010 est le nouveau
président jean michel fourgous souhaite
développer le numérique facteur de
croissance de demain il y a des
objectifs très élevés
dans cette agglomération d'abord au
niveau éducation nous nous travaillons
sur une école numérique parce que nos
entreprises qui sont très nombreuses de
très haut niveau de très haute valeur
ajoutée ont besoin de plus en plus de
compétences numériques et on s'évertue
qui avait cinq mille 5000 demandes sur
saint quentin dans le numérique google
n'a pas pu répondre donc de gros
objectifs de le faire sur un trappage
avec universités avec d'autres
organismes mais de bien sûr
d'intensifier ce cet objectif éducatif
le numérique représente près de 80
métiers pour répondre aux besoins des
entreprises le dispositif campus
numérique a été lancé cet été
quinze formations sélectionnées ont été
labellisés pour une durée d'un an dès
février autre priorité le développement
économique
classé dans le top ten des zones les
plus innovantes par le m haïti le
massachusetts institute of technology
l'agglomération veut rester compétitive
pour ce faire le territoire expérimente
les solutions innovantes développées par
les entreprises saint-quentinoise ainsi
en 2018 apparaîtra le premier schéma
directeur d'aménagement lumière cet
outil permettra d'optimiser et de gérer
à distance les trente neuf mille points
d'éclairage public des douze communes
connecter le territoire accompagne aussi
les grandes entreprises comme renault
rno kiki treuil sur le
la voiture du futur connectez autonome
électrique parce que demain on aura
certainement des bus qui s'inspireront
aussi de cette technique donc suivre
star est toujours faire que saint
quentin reste à la pointe du progrès
afin de connecter entreprises et acteurs
économiques
le territoire multiplie les rendez vous
tout au long de l'année la grande soirée
des entrepreneurs le salon be to be le
ski naïveté ou encore le ski business
day cette année le territoire sera
partenaire du pari de saclay innovation
journée afin de dévoiler aux
investisseurs étrangers tout le
potentiel du territoire
un territoire qui booste également
l'entrepreneuriat et l'innovation par le
biais du ski cube sans oublier l'emploi
le 29 mars au vélodrome entreprises
centres de formation et acteurs de
l'emploi seront présents pour favoriser
les recrutements locaux
autre enjeu la mobilité facteur
économique social environnemental majeur
surtout pour un territoire qui
participera à l'accueil des géo 2024 la
ligne 18 le doublement du pont guy
schuller entre morpain et la verrière la
vélostation bref ça va bouger en 2014
saint quentin en yvelines était la
première collectivités franciliennes a
approuvé son plan local de déplacement
afin de faciliter la mobilité le
territoire a lancé en 2017
des travaux d'envergure comme le
doublement du puch guy schuller le but
fluidifier le trafic sécuriser les voies
cyclables et piétonnes et instauré le
transport en site propre
depuis la gare de la verrière jusqu'à
celle de trappes autres aménagements
la ligne 18 prévus à l'origine pour
relier saint quentin en yvelines
à l'aéroport d'orly via le plateau de
saclay
l'extension de cette ligne de métro
jusqu'à l'agglomération est en attente
la décision devrait être con
affirmé en janvier côté bus 59 line sont
gérés par l'agglomération
toutes possèdent un système d' aide à
l'exploitation et information des
voyageurs
il s'agira en 2018 d'équilibrer les
transports en commun dans chacune des
communes du territoire
certaines étant moins bien desservies
actuellement les dispositifs alternatifs
sont aussi valoriser depuis la
mi-décembre 230 places de vélos sont
disponibles à la vélostation de la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines location de
vélo classique ou électrique et petites
réparations sont proposés
[Musique]
d'autres grands aménagements sont prévus
pour 2018 comme ici à voisins le
bretonneux ou à nouveau quartier devrait
sortir de terre pour 2020 500 logements
des commerces un pôle petite enfance une
maison de quartier et des aires de jeux
comme à la zac de l'aérostat à trappes
trappes s'agrandit 850 nouveaux
logements sont prévus dans la zone
d'aménagement concerté de l'aérostat 324
logement ou déjà été pourvus entre
location et accession à la propriété
350 logements sont toujours en phase de
construction
la troisième et dernière phase devrait
être lancée en 2018
avec 250 logements à l'acte et saint
quentin en yvelines c'est aussi une
force commerciale de territoire est le
deuxième pôle économique de l'ouest
parisien après la défense le territoire
souhaite conserver cette place de leader
sur le marché notamment grâce à une
palette commerciale diversifiée comme
ici à l'espace saint quentin plus de
2400 commerces et services
193 grande surface répartis sur plus de
300 mille mètres carrés pour un chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 2 milliards
d'euros par an pour faire face à la
concurrence le territoire souhaite
mettre l'accent sur la qualité et la
complémentarité de l'offre des douze
communes avec différents projets de gros
projets commerciaux qui ont été été
validée déjà il ya un moment
skywest qui retrouve voilà maintenant
une nouvelle dynamique puisque on allait
furet du nord qui sont arrivés
les autres cellules sur ton
recommercialisation avec la volonté du
groupe hammerson qui gère l'ensemble
d'avoir une totalité des locaux occupés
d'ici la fin 2010 8 d'autres activités
tournées vers les familles devraient
compléter l'offre de skywest autre
projet d'envergure l'open sky à plaisir
40 nouvelles boutiques sur 37
millimètres carrés d'ici la fin de
l'année 2018
il faut trouver en effet une
complémentarité entre les zones
commerciales existantes de périphérie
avec laquelle il faut faire évidemment
et les commerces de proximité des
actions qu'il faut trouver en parallèle
avec les villes puisqu'elles restent
compétentes sur le commerce de proximité
et l'agglomération sur les zones
commerciales sans pour autant les
étendre dans l'avenir on va travailler
c'est la stratégie que nous menons en
qualité la qualité des enseignes la
manière dont on circule dans les
ensembles commerciaux et surtout un an
un point très important c'est
d'urbanisme commercial
autrement dit rénovation et aménagement
des zones commerciales construite il ya
trente ans afin de rester compétitif et
éviter les friches commerciales
quant aux villes de trappes et l'encours
et maurepas elles seront accompagnés
dans leur projet de redynamisation
commerciale
autre rendez vous pour les commerçants
le 9 avril prochain
au programme présentation des solutions
pour développer leur visibilité et leur
activité
santé contrat de vie l'égalité femmes
hommes seront aussi à l'ordre du jour en
2018 pour plus d'égalité sur le
territoire est lé nouveau contrat local
de santé a été mise en place avec un
nouveau dispositif presque réforme
portée par l'institut de promotion de la
santé et la direction des sports de
l'agglomération il permettra aux
médecins de prescrire une activité
physique aux patients souffrant
d'affections de longue durée de maladie
chronique ou encore de surpoids
les maisons de santé fleurissent sur
l'agglomération trappe
montigny le bretonneux ou encore
guyancourt les médecins se regroupent
pour mieux répondre aux besoins de la
population
autre priorité l'égalité femmes hommes
le territoire a décidé de sensibiliser
au sein de structures locales du
territoire le but identifier les
pratiques actions existantes pour
encourager les initiatives reconnus pour
leur efficacité depuis 2010 est
l'agglomération a mis en oeuvre un
unique contrat de ville pour les douze
communes du territoire soit 34500 saint
quentinois des quartiers prioritaires
pour davantage d'écouté d'accompagnement
la culture les loisirs les grands
événements ponctuent aussi l'avis
saint-quentinoise et pas des moindres en
septembre 2018 saint-quentin-en-yvelines
accueillera sa première ryder cup de
l'art urbain au musée de la ville une
scène nationale des résidences
d'artistes
la culture est un des points qui marque
l'image de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
premier service de proximité le réseau
des médiathèques cinq nouvelles
structures ont rejoint le réseau au 1er
janvier
la mise en réseau sera déployé sur
plusieurs années à terme de nouveaux
services à la disposition des habitants
ressources numériques prêt de documents
et programmation d'événements communs du
25 au 30 septembre prochain
l'agglomération accueillera la première
ryder cup française au golf national
les 24 meilleurs joueurs de golf
américain et européens seront réunis
durant six jours la ryder cup c'est 750
millions de téléspectateurs dans 180
un pays et des retombées économiques
d'environ 100 millions d'euros ainsi que
la renommée internationale pour le
territoire avant les jeux olympiques de
2024 dont six épreuves se dérouleront
sur les sites de l'agglomération
c'est vrai que là dessus les saint
quentin et comme on le dit souvent
béni des dieux parce qu'avoir quatre
sites olympiques sur 50 un bon il y en a
des golfs comme les plus prestigieux et
les plus difficiles au monde un danger
au on à la colline d'elancourt que la
plus élevée d'ile-de-france effet on a
le vélodrome qui est un des plus grands
vélodrome d'europe
tout cela ce sont de très bonnes
nouvelles plus la ryder cup directement
l'année prochaine qui est la troisième
compétition la plus médiatisée du monde
vous dira qu'à voir tout ça en même
temps
et plutôt réconfortant on a tous des
chantiers des objectifs très élevés
culturels sportifs la santé
l'entrepreneuriat l'économie et puis le
transport bien sûr mais on est à peu
près une belle panoplie pour réussir un
beau projet de qualité de vie en tout
cas pour les saint quentinois ici vous
savez désormais tout sur les projets
saint quentinois pour 2018
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures ciao
[Musique]